All right, everybody. So here is example number two looking at GBPUSD on the 10 minute time from now
And the reason why I'm looking at 10 minute is because if I go to the six minute time from you can see that
even though we have one verbal gap and
There's another further gap here, right?
But the range is too small and the take profit would have been already hit if I was on six minute
So to avoid looking at this I would go to 10 minute and we have this one big fairly gap
I wouldn't say big, but yeah
And you can clearly see we took out some form of liquidity, right? Or you could say break of structure and
Over here we have a fair valley gap now once
The candle closes it closes below it. It becomes inverse revenue gap. So this revenue gap becomes inverse
All right
Now my entry would be on the retest and this is the closest low that is gonna be my take profit level
Now it's giving me 1.31. So I can move my stop up a bit like that
I'm just gonna give you one two one
Now if this level is hit before the entry then my setup would become invalid
All right, so this is my take profit level if I play this through you will see that we go down
But we do not take out the take profit level and from there onwards you can see that the take profit level was hit
Now you can see that
could have probably
Took some partial zers and then maybe you could have got got closed at break even
But the higher target would have been these these equal lows here or the issue low here
And you can see that the issue low was taken
But most probably if you didn't take your entire profits here, which I mostly do
Because that's when I get above 70% win rate when I take one two ones and target the closest lows or highs
But if you took you some partials here and then you let the trade running and your main target was this
You could have gotten around
one two one two two point eight or one two three you could say
so a very simple trading model that works brilliantly it requires no daily bus and
It is a very very powerful
Trust me. All right. Let me give you guys one more example